hi I'm Erik Bosse in glass follows the
tradition of all in night Shyamalan
movies and the way it throws a whole
bunch of stuff at you at the end to
confuse you and make YouTube videos
about it we didn't know until a
post-credits scene that split was a
sequel to unbreakable unbreakable being
a movie that itself ended with a
fascinating twist that was actually two
origin stories revealing Sam Jackson's
Elijah price mr. glass as a villain
mastermind here I'm gonna explain the
ending of glass answering the big
questions you might have coming out of
this movie and of course spoiler warning
if you haven't seen glass no one forced
you to click on this video but I'm
asking you to go see the movie before I
ruin your life okay so what was the
twist of glass glass actually ends with
three third-act reveals which may or may
not have been twist depending on whether
or not your expectations were actually
subverted in my case I considered them
reveals because I felt like I had no
information and then I had some
information that I wish I knew earlier
first reveal David Dunn Bruce Willis
works with the son Joseph Spencer treat
Clark returning from unbreakable and
after David gets arrested Joseph does a
bit of research essentially googling a
name sharp sleuthing there and realizes
that the father of Kevin Crum James
MacAvoy died in these same train crash
that David survived at the beginning of
unbreakable eastrail one-77 so in a way
Elijah who sabotage this train is
responsible for creating the super
identities of both David and Kevin with
David discovering his abilities from
this incident and Kevin growing up
without a father to help him get the
mental help he needed to avoid splitting
into the various identities of the Horde
sure ii revealed doctor Ellie's taper
Sarah paulsen is actually a member of a
shadowy organization that seeks to hide
the existence of superheroes from the
world more on that in a second and third
reveal Elijah's breakout from the
facility was actually a suicide mission
in front of his many security cameras as
possible so that he could film David and
Kevin super heroics to eventually share
them with the world let's go back and
talk about that doctor staple reveal
first because it's the most bonkers
throughout the film staple sits down
with Elijah Kevin and David trying to
convince them that they're super heroism
is actually a delusion a result of
untreated brain damage and what when she
tries to use the laser device to fix
this part of Elijah's brain it doesn't
work because he it already removed the
focus lens from the machine but after
the three prisoners escape and Duke it
out in the parking lot
sniper shoots Kevin and we see that this
sniper has a clover tattoo on his wrist
so does dr. staple so do a lot of these
guys she touches David sand and he sees
in a vision that she is part of an
ancient network one that has been around
for 10,000 years she says they
apparently gather at public restaurants
and wait for the last outsider to leave
the room before everyone quiets down and
starts their meeting because I guess the
only way to meet in secret is to flash
mob this organization tracks down people
with super abilities and silences them
through imprisonments or making them
think that they're crazy or killing them
why do they do this well according to
staple these individuals inevitably
clash and that violence escalates and
sucks in innocent people creates
collateral damage so basically I guess
they're like Hydra if hydras main
prerogative was to tell kids Tana
doesn't exist but what do these clover
tattoos mean these guys Irish well
actually the three of you clover or the
Shamrock is an important part of Irish
iconography it has been used as a symbol
of the Holy Trinity in Christian
theology and as a symbol for st. Patrick
the Catholic figure who drove the snakes
out of Ireland perhaps that's how this
organization sees itself superhero
exterminators or maybe the number three
corresponds to the three supers of this
movie
David Kevin Elijah like maybe superhero
figures appear three at a time and they
have to quash them in triplets and
that's what they do to these three they
drown David and a few inches of water a
pothole that filled with water from the
ruptured tank and doctor stapled begs
him to say that she convinced him that
his powers aren't real she doesn't want
him to die she probably just rather have
him live thinking that his superpowers
aren't really in existence but the
overseer can't pretend that he's normal
the guy can bench infinite amounts he's
been using his powers hundreds of times
so yeah he dies along with Kevin and
Elijah in his final moments staple tells
Elijah that he was right about his
perception of the world through the lens
of comic books that comic books it turns
out really are a form of media that
accurately reflects the secret truth
about super-powered humans throughout
Society into nowadays with something
like 10 superhero movies coming out
every year it must be harder than ever
for the shamrock society to keep Debbie
downing everyone but do they ultimately
fail because Shyamalan has one last
width slash reveal for us so what was
Elijah zhh plan well from the end of
unbreakable Elijah's main goal has
always been to out super-powered people
around the world
it's why he kept causing mass deaths
hoping an unbreakable survivor would
crawl out from the rubble until it
eventually happened with David Dunn
I was just great a suffering isn't that
he's locked away and abused by guards
it's that people think his belief in
superheroes is crazy you know what the
scariest thing is to not know your place
in this world do not know why are you
here it's just an awful feeling he hoped
that David Dunn's heroism making the
paper would be the beginning and for
years it worked
David roamed the streets as a vigilante
people started calling him the overseer
but then David got locked up with Kevin
and Elijah
so Elijah's plan had to change so we
orchestrated a breakout and he claimed
that the destination was the new Osaka
Tower in downtown Philly which would
give him and a superheroes a huge
spotlight but of Sakha tower was just a
mystery
instead Elijah just made sure to break
out in the most visible way possible
passing dozens of security cameras that
staple had bragged about installing
running into a number of staff and
guards and getting caught in a police
shootout in the parking lot but before
he broke out he stopped in the
facility's security terminal and typed
in a bunch of lines of code to upload
the security video feed to a private
server the one belonging to his mother
so that she would now possess video
evidence of what dr. staple was trying
to hide and with the help of Josefa
casey they released this video footage
on social media and watched in a train
station as everyone's phones and tablets
light up with these insane viral videos
because that's how the internet works
right people see clips of stunts on
Chive or do perfect drop everything and
then say oh my god Superman exists what
else in this Jamrock society been hiding
from me but my question for you is would
you have preferred if glass hinted at
the existence of this anti superhero
society earlier maybe lay the groundwork
for this shadowy villainous call to make
it clear what Elijah was fighting
against or did you like it better as a
twist reveal comment down below with
your thoughts and follow new rock stars
on Twitter at new rockstars me on
Twitter and Instagram add me a boss and
subscribe to new rockstars where we
tackle the big questions we all want to
know about superhero movies like when
are they gonna get to Osaka Tower never
it's just like itchy scratchy and
poopsie never getting into the fireworks
factory like just go to the fun place
[Music]